good morning Tim oh you're the king of
the Segway daddy yep the ps-aguié all
right
are you Pro Mayfield or anti Mayfield
with this situation I'm generally Pro
mate Mayfield on almost everything
he's probably exaggerating taking it a
little farther than it needs to be I do
think it's strange he's got a little
Kevin Durant enemy pay his attention to
a lot of criticism out there that he
doesn't really eat but you know in
general the weirdest thing to me in this
whole situation is and you know this to
you we know people in the media who make
about one to two percent of what a head
coach makes and they have non-compete
clauses in their contract when they lose
their job they can't do anything with
the competitor for a year how do you go
from a head coach in the NFL so two
weeks later working for a team in your
division yeah and I heard Peter King say
the NFL has to address that that you
can't just if if somebody loses their
job and then they could all of a sudden
show up on somebody else's staff but you
know I understand Hugh Jackson saying
look you don't want me anymore I want to
stick it to you so I'm gonna go to the
Bengals and I get that you know Baker
Mayfield feels like you're a traitor
that you did that I understand all of
that
I just I'm kind of surprised that Baker
Mayfield is still continuing to talk
about this when it's Hugh Jackson and
it's the Bengals yeah and I think that's
part of the competitive nature of Baker
that sometimes he he wants to remind us
that it's there we kind of know it's
there it's kind of like okay we know
what kind of competitor you are you
really don't have to keep going on this
all right this game tonight if you know
we talked to bud a month ago where we
were looking at you know doomsday for
this Dallas situation with dak Prescott
future you know Jason Garrett's future
here with Jerry ever win a Super Bowl
now all of a sudden the the star is back
and it's brighter than ever so what kind
of chance do you give Dallas tonight
against New Orleans
I think I give them more of a chance
than most around here we'll put it at
31% Dan but I give them a good chance to
cover that seven-point spread I mean I
just think if you look back one month
New Orleans went to Baltimore beat him
24 to 23 Baltimore's got a little better
defense than Dallas maybe but not any
they don't have a Ravens and Reed Ray
Lewis defense and Dallas has a better
offense I just think they will be able
to run the ball more than other teams
have run it on the Saints and that
proves not to be true then they're dead
and they'll lose by 20 but I think they
can run it and you know have 32 minutes
time of possession and and just keep it
from getting ridiculous like it gets
with the Saints sometimes you imagine if
the Cowboys win well I mean that would
be that'll still surprise me a fair
amount for sure and you know there's
people around here that are dreading
that just because they know or they feel
like they know okay that's three more
years to Jason Garrett but who knows I
mean who knows if they do that then you
know maybe they're gonna end up ten and
six or whatever and and actually compete
in the playoffs but they face tell you
that's they still got to do that first
okay but the questions here it has Jason
Garrett done enough that he's going to
keep his job no no I think I still think
this could go the wrong way and it
wouldn't it saves lose tonight stumbles
somewhere else and they even if they win
the division at nine and seven and it
lose the wild-card game I don't know
that he's I don't know that he's a lock
to come back at all
and I think for sure they would Jerry
would make him change out the offense
coordinator Scott Linehan but I think I
think I think there the number of ways
Jason is still not it's still not back
after this year but have you said to
cowboy fans you can win the next three
or lose the next three if if winning the
next three means Jason Garrett stays or
losing the next three means he's gone
you gotta you gotta fixed a I mean you
got a yeah you got to pick a win I mean
I I've said I think people exaggerate
all this too much we really never know
exactly you know what makes coaches and
you know we think after eight years I
Jason Garrett has a certain limit and
he's not going to really get to that far
but I don't know that there's no real
way to take analytics and prove it
there's just a way to look at his
numbers and say he's a bum 500 coach
hasn't done well he's only got to
january twice out of seven seasons and
he's won one game there does that mean
it couldn't happen i don't know i think
you have to ride the winning whenever
you get it and then and then live with
live with what happens and his dak
prescott going to be extended so he you
see the franchise quarterback with the
big number coming his way
i think it's getting better for him
although we could debate the size of the
number but you know the funny thing dan
is like at halftime in the last game i
was i was tweeting about a bari Cooper
after three and a half games he was
averaging 11 23 yards per catch after
being a 14 and 15 yard guy for three
seasons in Oakland and just saying is
this ever gonna work or is he just just
what he's relegated to here now based on
two plays a five yard pass he turned
into 40 and then a nice 20 to 25 yard
pass he turned into 90 we've decided
that everything works and he's a this is
everything's gonna be great here so and
maybe it is but you know I think we need
to see a little more of that before we
know for sure where we think that can
take this team he's tim cavanaugh
columnist Dallas Morning News and star
panelist on ESPN's around the horn
joining us Dan Patrick show now when you
go into a game like this as a columnist
do you have a column ready for the
Cowboys being blown out and do you have
a column ready if Dallas would somehow
pull this out I think a good columnist
always does that day and I might think
about it I I do not but I've only been
doing this column thing for 21 years so
maybe maybe maybe near 22 I'll think
those servers now we don't have a lot of
time I know everybody's really
interested in newspaper deadlines and
sorry what are newspapers what is that
what is that you're talking about yeah
what is this newspaper you're talking
about why are people throwing things in
my yard no I mean you have ideas but you
don't know I the correct answer for me
is no I do not
all right one more thing the Texas
Oklahoma game this weekend now the thing
that stood out to me is that if Oklahoma
does the horns down gesture they could
be flagged 15 yards in the big 12 title
game how is it that Texas can do the
horns up and Oklahoma can't do the horns
down gesture Tim how is it that my alma
mater has a long voyage Network and the
others don't we get to play by our own
rules we have all the judges in the
state we have all the power it's a
stupid thing and will Grier got a big
penalty yeah he did it after you know it
that was 15 yards on the kickoff
if Tom Herman hadn't used up all his
time outs before the two-point
conversion that could have been a huge
play so I mean it's just silliness I of
course they should be able to do that
and but I like the fact that Lincoln
Riley checked with the league office I
think he probably said something like
when we score six or seven touchdowns
Saturday are we allowed on any of those
to do horns down how silly is this but
Oklahoma crazy they can't do it but
Texas can so that that's not taunting if
Texas does it but if Oklahoma does the
orange down it is in fairness that's
that's a Texas so you can do like if
you're a Baylor bear you can put a claw
or whatever it is they do or some of the
other little symbols people have but
they they can put it all up if they want
it's silly Fred she's got Prince he's
got the title for your column if New
Orleans wins Fritzi do you went off
fingers up to Kayla shot New Orleans
wins I got how about them Saints and if
and if the Cowboys shock the Saints I
got Hudak Tim doesn't do the the title
of the he doesn't do the headline I'm
sorry I'm sorry do you control the heavy
newspaper background at all I've read
him high school I've read them I
delivered a newspaper did you yes I did
which one it was the the Cincinnati Post
all right
Cincinnati poster yes it was yeah
afternoon newspaper but I of course was
23 years of age when I was doing it so
so you can so there you go you have a
couple of titles or headlines for your
columns yeah
courtesy of Fritz already are you out
there are you going around the horn
tonight I am today on the new augmented
reality around the org yes the Tony
renew Tony reality show the new colors
and all of us yes yeah I got it I got it
you know what's gonna happen is you guys
gonna be replaced by digital columnist
at some point like very soon yes that
day yeah correct
keep your head up though all right good
luck tonight well I'll be watching all
right thank you
there's a better chance of winning
tonight you on around the horn or the
Cowboys oh well I gave the Cowboys a 31%
tip yeah I have a 25 but if Woody's on
there you got a little better odds thank
you Tim thank you buddy that's uh Tim
Couch a Dallas Morning News for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
you
[Music]